[Music]
the american dream is that we all have
the chance to make it be rich we all
have the chance
lularoe is a multi-level marketing
company they sell shirts and dresses the
reason that they became so popular is
they sold these leggings they called
them buttery soft leggings i love this
print it like reminds me of quilting and
crosstalking and arts and crafts i was
struck by how passionate these women
were my entire lifestyle became
everything lularoe it's like contagious
events parties galas it was so fun
it was more than a clothing company to
me hey lularoe we're back ready to sail
they sell you this idea that you can
grow it into money beyond what you can
imagine you buy in sell a bunch of
banana leggings all of your friends are
like wow this is an amazing business
opportunity and you're like i know would
you like to sign up underneath me i'm
like finally this is something that i
can do
and then you join a few facebook groups
and you start buying more and then
eventually someone's gonna tell you i
think you would be amazing at this
opportunity i recently got involved with
that was innocuous gentle genuine
comfort just kidding we're gonna eat you
alive
we get the boxes and it was like what
the hell is this yuck colors weird
shades of mustard when you're working in
production there's always this balance
of quality and quantity and with lularoe
it was like they started to pill and
fall apart sales just started to drop
the common thread is getting in way over
their heads and they're just trapped and
the lamb stands for mom's losing money
people lost houses marriages i'm
constantly trying to make up for what i
lost they're basically going after the
stay-at-home mom where there aren't a
lot of other options the greed and
corruption goes so
deep the saddest part is that the
american dream can become instead a
nightmare i'm shocked that i drank that
much kool-aid